eh bien le 22 octobre 41 vers 10h un
officier allemand s'est présentée à moi
et m'a apporté un ordre de la
kommandantur de châteaubriant par
laquelle n'avions plus le droit de
sortir et j'ai trouvé l'officier
allemand qui avait apporté le le billet
en question et puis il m'a dit monsieur
il faut se tenir à notre disposition et
remonter tout de suite parce que vous
voyez les mitrailleuses là sont prêtes à
servir or je lui ai demandé pourquoi tu
me dis qu'est ce qui pouvait se passer
il m'a dit monsieur qui va se passer un
grand malheur
l'histoire est parfois rebelle à
certaines évidences et on peut oublier
qu'il y a trente ans sont otages ont été
fusillés en 48 heures en france pour les
allemands pour impressionner l'opinion
les premiers 27 communistes était alors
détenu à choisel un camp de prisonniers
politiques près de châteaubriant en
bretagne
attendait environ 30 mètres un petit peu
long à l'appui alors beaucoup plus haut
d'autres étaient alors s'est bâti mort
et qui sont là les bâtiments et les
vieux bâtiments la cuisine au gardien il
revient les gendarmes le gendarme
français confrontés à ce moment là qui
s'occupait des oreillers les prisonniers
les plus jeunes y ait plus tard lorsque
le camp à fond dès demain c'était le
gardien chef qui étaient là bas au début
c'était la crise et puis alors là les
petites maisons c'était ce qu'on appelle
le mitard quoi j'ai faits prisonniers
lors la baraque où se trouvaient les
otages qui ont été emmenés ensuite à la
carrière et est par ici je crois aussi
que la baraque le goûter les prisonniers
étaient environ une trentaine de mètres
la
rente ai quand même qu'il se passait
quelque chose soit fait c'était pour
comme d'habitude soit à chanter dans
cette barre à plat et rose demandé ce
qu'ils pensaient y vous pouvez produit
n'est d'ailleurs
est ce que vous allez me dire monsieur
racine à cette époque que vous
choisissiez de la politique comme ou pas
du tout bon pour lui et est ce que vous
en avez fait depuis permet est ce que à
l'époque ce qui s'est passé ça ça vous a
marqué ah oui un peu ah oui là mais les
gens n'auraient pensé qu'il était
capable de figuier froidement comme ça
il va tâcher
[Musique]
le parti communiste clandestin depuis sa
dissolution à septembre 39 avait déjà
organisé ces groupes de guérilla urbaine
et multiplié les attentats
[Musique]
mais la sphère de châteaubriant commence
en fait le 20 octobre 1941 lorsque huit
heures du matin un commando à bas à
nantes le colonel oates
von steuben agl gouverneur militaire
allemand du territoire occupé veut un
exemple pour briser la résistance qui
s'organise il faut pour la première fois
fusillé en groupe des dizaines d'otages
il en parla plus je le ministre de
l'intérieur de vichy qui désigne d'abord
27 des communistes enfermé à
châteaubriant alors toute une histoire
commence sont réunis dans la nuit du vin
du 21 au 22 et ils ont discuté
michels les a mis au courant de
l'information qu'il venait d'avoir alors
naturellement les gens du milieu pro
possible c'est un assassinat il faut se
soulever c'est bon on a envisagé
une comment réagir non on pas une émeute
on envisager
de se révolter dans le camp et c'est
alors que michel a expliqué nous sommes
sans armes gardé par des hommes qui ont
tout ce qu'il faut pour noyer dans le
sang tout tout
tout insurrection tout et par conséquent
ce serait le massacre de tout le camp
or la seule question c'est d'envisager
comment ceux qui sont désignés
allons mourir
ensuite le lendemain
il se trouve que c'est l'abbé moyon curé
de béret qui est autorisé à voir les
les amis que les camarades de qui sont
rassemblés à la baratte des otages
naturellement aucun d'entre eux
ne croient au ciel mais ils reçoivent le
curé
avec
beaucoup de sympathie car c'est ce sont
les termes c'est le dernier français
avec lequel ils pourront parler ils
disent qu'ils n'ont pas besoin des
services de la religion mais qu'il se
sente frère avec lui en tant que
français et non deux sentiments d'amour
de la patrie et il est resté avec eux
jusqu'au moment l'officier allemand a
dit c'est le moment il faut partir
monsieur malheureux beurre puisque vous
étiez les les témoins les plus directes
est ce que vous pouvez me dire ce qui
s'est passé exactement pour vous le le
22 octobre dès le matin qu'est ce que
vous avez vu et bien le 22 octobre 41
vers 10h un officier allemand se
présenter à moi et m'a apporté un ordre
de la commande en tueur de chateaubriand
dans lequel n'avions plus de doigts de
sortir
alors aussitôt j'ai mis mon mari au
courant et il est descendu dans la
carrière
et j'ai trouvé l'officier allemand qui
avait apporté le le billet en question
et puis il m'a dit monsieur il faut se
tenir à notre disposition et remonter
tout de suite parce que vous voyez les
mitrailleuses là sont prêtes à servir or
je lui ai demandé pourquoi
quick est ce qui pouvait se passer il
m'a dit monsieur qui va se passer un
grand malheur
à laurent ensuite au bout d'un certain
temps nous avons entendu les camions
arrivés les premiers a descendu
directement la carrière et les deux
autres ont été arrêtés face à la maison
alors là ils chantaient
et ses 2 que je voyais les allemands les
mettre en jour mais je ne voyais pas les
otages il était caché par le talus et
par les branches et bien aussitôt la 3e
saint bruno mis dehors là c'était pour
voir les camions passent et avec les
corps qui étaient entassées dedans et ce
camion où le sang coule et derrière en
remontant la rend qui se vidait du sein
des otages nous avons marché pendant
plus d'un mois sur le son
c'était affreux
en fait cette fusillade elle est secoué
l'opinion publique jusque là il faut
bien le dire assez résignés il en est
ainsi dans toutes les guerres et faire
virer la guerre clandestine
c'est pourquoi chaque année fin octobre
depuis 30 ans vingt mille personnes se
retrouvent à châteaubriant c'est plus
qu'un symbole
une autre façon d'envisager l'avenir
[Musique]
mais
on a pu reprocher à l'auteur de
l'attentât de nantes qui vit encore de
ne pas s'être dénoncés lorsqu'il a su
que tant d'hommes allait être fusillé à
sa place jacques duclos répond
à côté ça c'était dans son sillage
c'est comme si fabien quand il ya eu le
commandant ghit les liens qui a été tué
qui l'a tué dans le métro métro barbès
et est allé dire aux nazis 20 messieurs
c'est moi qui ai fait ça la chorale côté
quand on s'engage dans le combat on ne
dit pas qu'il ne va pas qu'on fasse
appel quand on s'engage dans le combat
on sait très bien qu'il y aura des
victimes ça c'est inévitable mais enfin
fallait faire le pas il s'agissait
d'organiser la bière riga dans notre
pays et non pas seulement la guérilla
dans les maquis mais même dans une
certaine mesure la guérilla urbaine ce
qui a été fait par conséquent c'était
impensable qu'un homme qui avait un
ennemi n'est ce pas dans le feu de
combat alice s'est livré lui-même
l'ennemi parce que selon elle est
arrêtée du tout on ne les tuez lui il
n'en fit de plus clé des otages on a
fait une victime de plus puis après vous
auriez pu chercher des volontaires
prophétique pour se livrer à des actes
d'audace contre les nuits je n'ai pu en
chercher
si au bout de la faire il y avait la
confession et nous nous avons nous lu
des chutes la gestapo avait arrêté et la
police de vichy qui collaborait
étroitement avait arrêté des hommes
qui travaillaient directement en liaison
avec la direction des partis par
conséquent nous étions dans une
situation très difficile ils on peut
dire que nous étions en pleine
réorganisation de notre appareil central
du parti lorsque le drame de
châteaubriant nous est tombé dessus ce
que vous voyez qu'ils aient eu de la
peur des des autorités françaises de
l'époque et des autorités allemandes une
volonté délibérée de briser le parti qui
était candidat en ce qui concerne le
choix
des
otages des martyrs de châteaubriant
c'est clair ils ont choisi délibérément
des communistes à l'entée à sous jeux ça
n'a pas été la même chose là il ya eu un
choix plus éclectique et les catholiques
il ya eu des communistes il y avait des
communistes partout il n'y avait pas que
des communistes mais ici ils ont voulu
véritablement porter un coup à notre
parti et c'est le dénommé pêcheurs qui
était un ancien toyotiste c'était un
ancien une sorte d'énarques de l'époque
sorte de polytechniciens passées au
service des traces qui était devenu
ministre l'intérieur l'homme à tout
faire de laval et c'est lui qui
personnellement a choisi les vingt-sept
de martyrs communiste châteaubriant il
les a bien choisi faut bien le dire il a
choisi des ouvriers et plus ou moins
connus il a choisi des militants bien
connus la choisit des élus il a choisi
des jeunes ce n'est pas par hasard qu'il
a choisi le jeune guy môquet parce que
son père était député communiste tout
simplement
[Musique]